và phán chỉ đạo điều phương đã cần chương kích hòa thể thống ứng phó khẩn cấp.
Loan công tác của 18 mặt trận tổ phút Việt Nam Tình cảm au.
Phố hợp cùng sợ núng nghiệp và mù trường,
văn phòng trong thiết tài tình đã trực tiếp súng hiện chương trực tiếp nằm bắt tình hình.
Các tờ quan trình muồn đào của hợp trả trẻ với chính quyền,
các sã giả sóa, thống kê chính xác mực lộ thị thạc để có phương an hút trước kì thôi.
Lực lượng tài trốn ở đã được quy đọng thời đào để giúp lợn người dân thú giọng đồ đào.
Sợ chứ ở lại nhà cửa bị hướng hồng,
tổ chức các phát kinh phí hỗ trợ văn đau nhằm giúp các hồ dân vùng thiên tài sớm ở định là của sống
và thuộc hồi các bạn động sản xuất.